it's april fool's day beware the smart
alex out there that may try to trick you
in some way our darren gantt with the
tweet last night psa for all amateur
comedians getting ready for a big
tomorrow much like the special occasion
drinkers on new year's and st patrick's
day your attempt is neither sufficient
nor necessary no seriously it's really
not funny don't hit send please do not
do the april fool's gags we beg you do
not do the april fool's gags and in
honor of april fool's day real nfl
stories that we thought were fake when
we first heard of them
uh chris i'm gonna go ahead and give you
the first pick i don't think there's a
trivia question so i think you get the
first pick i'm in a good mood today for
a change okay okay that's good uh all
right there i mean there's some good
ones actually and and uh i think the
first one i'm gonna go with that i think
totally shocked me
i'm gonna go with barry sanders retiring
after nine years in the nfl that's one
to me where i'll still look at it and go
man barry sanders is still arguably the
best running back in the game certainly
in the conversation you're going oh man
he's on the ark he's going to be the
all-time leading rusher in the nfl what
he's retiring he's still like in his a
minus game i mean he was still electric
and untackable uh uh uh that's not even
a word but you couldn't tackle him space
okay yeah it's close enough he's still
like tremendous long speed and quicks
and you know i just really didn't see a
drop off in his game at all to me that
was one of the shockers of all time uh
with barry sanders retiring
i agree with you but let me just say
this and i wasn't in the business at the
time so i wasn't privy to the whispers
and the rumors that something was going
on but there was talk that something was
going on and barry sanders wired a
little differently than other football
players it really wasn't one of those
things where when you know it happened
it was like oh my god i can't believe it
it's like yeah you know what it kind of
makes sense the the where the lions are
where they've been where the vikings
were at the time in the process of
taking over the division with randy moss
entering his second year it made sense
when you sat down and thought about it
and it happened not long before training
camp so we had time to process it before
week one the one that i think is the
clear number one pick is the andrew luck
retirement because none of those factors
was there there was no reason to think
andrew luck was retiring there were no
whispers he was thinking about retiring
it caught everyone off guard and it
happened two weeks before the season
started and it was that classic burned
into your memory i know exactly where i
was my wife and i were in new york for
our anniversary we're at a show i turned
my phone on and the first thing i see
it's like somebody hacked our twitter
account there's no way andrew luck's
retired that one i'll never forget and i
still don't understand it to this day
how he could walk away from football
when uh when uh you know he still had so
much to give and so much to play
intensely personal decision but still
shocking when it happened
shocking i mean so shocking that i was
sitting there watching tv with my father
and had a friend in the house and we're
sitting there i can't remember what we
were watching at the time but he goes
hey did you guys just see that breaking
news on the bottom he goes andrew luck's
retiring and we all looked at him like
ah shut up dude you don't know what
you're talking about and he's like no
you need to rewind it you know we had to
rewind the dvr so that was a shocker
there's no doubt about it and i did not
have a had that on my list uh so good
job by you all right here's really the
all-time shocker i mean this is the
all-time shocker what
there's a police chase involving o.j
simpson okay i don't mean to go
challenge flag what are you doing he was
retired for 15 years
i don't care gosh hall of famer he was
jumping cars and
you know uh
car commercials and everything
yes that was a shocker of all time i
could still remember i was at a pool
party in eighth grade and like one of
the parents coming out going o.j
simpson's in like a high sp high-speed
car chase with the police and you're
like what
what and just going inside watching that
that was one of the most unbelievable
events of my lifetime i will never
forget that and everything that you know
came after it but a shocker because o.j
simpson had a squeaky clean image to
that point you know i really looked up
to him thought he was awesome so that to
me will always go down all time
and maybe you were busy at the time
doing things that 13 year olds do or
doing things that 13 year old chris sims
did but that story had already developed
to the point where it was the next
logical step the walls were closing in
on him that stop being such a lawyer you
didn't think he was gonna get in a
police chase and go down the highway for
four hours you didn't think that that
was a surprise yes i know there was
inkling that we thought oh maybe he
was guilty but we didn't think that was
gonna happen
but i didn't refuse to believe it it
wasn't a surprise in that context
because of everything else that was
happening all right next one for me
brett favre unretiring in 2008. the the
i remember he was on david letterman's
show in april and he made a comment like
you know who knows how i'm going to feel
when july rolls around and that was the
first time i thought
really could there be a chance but even
when it happened and it was another one
is where i remember exactly where i was
we had a family trip to washington dc we
were at the zoo for crying out loud and
on my phone came the word that brett
favre had unretired and he intends to
rejoin the green bay packers and it
ended up being a huge giant mess for a
couple of days or longer while the
packers figured out what to do with him
but that one did come out of the blue
you know we'd always known he was going
to retire we never thought he was going
to unretired the unretired so many times
were kind of used to it that first one
though was a stunner
it was it was a stunner but you know to
be a jerk like you so i can challenge
you a little bit all right i mean he had
like threatened to retirement for many
years before that never threatened on
retirement i know i know he didn't i
know but i had to be a lawyer for a
second either way because you're gonna
sit here and try to crap on every one of
my picks all right stick to football
stick to football here all right so yeah
you you hit one story from last summer
with andrew luck i'm going to last
summer too you know i i forgot about
this i got a little help from pete dimma
little little light and lighted lightest
one of our producers back there okay
but this was a shocker and one of those
when you saw the news you were like no
way can that be true
antonio brown's
foot issue
that to me was like in all time when i
heard that story i was like first off
what is going on with this feat and then
when i had people tell me in the know
that hey he actually froze the bottom of
his feet off going in the cryotherapy
machine
i i didn't want to believe it even
though i knew the people that were
telling me knew exactly
that that had happened that is just
absolutely
unbelievable to me that's one of the
most amazing stories here in recent
history in the nfl one of our best
players antonio brown
froze the bottom of his feed off because
he didn't think his feet would freeze in
a cryotherapy machine even though every
other humans does
what a shock that you would pick a story
that you had a hand in advancing and
breaking is one of your stories i'm
stunned i'm stunned that you would do
that
well yes i i didn't mean to do that it
just is amazing nonetheless and i gave i
gave a credit to to uh pete
demolinololitis but it was really matt
casey i think who sent that text so
sorry matt casey
let me tell you if we're going to go
that route with stories we had a hand in
breaking i'll go with the vikings
dumping randy moss in 2005. i didn't
believe it when i first heard it may
happen people called me crazy and worse
when i started writing about it at pft
that was the only platform we had at the
time that was pre-radio pre-podcast
pre-everything and then ultimately the
vikings dumped randy moss onto the
raiders for a first round pick napoleon
kaufman and a seventh round pick me one
of the great receivers of all time what
are you doing and he had a great season
that was the offseason after the two
touchdowns against the green bay packers
where he pretended to moon the crowd and
rubbed his rear end against the goal
post what a disgusting act as joe buck
said they traded him after that season
it's not like his skills were slipping
it was amazing and they didn't get
nearly enough for him so that one
stunned me when it happened chris yeah
that was that was a stunner there's no
doubt all right so give me some other
ones on your list i mean i remember
being shocked by joe montana you know
just the trade to the chiefs even though
we kind of knew it was gonna happen that
he was gonna get traded and not be in
the 49ers it's still joe montana and
when you hear that news i remember being
shocked as a little kid i remember also
herschel walker because i thought
herschel walker at the time was like the
greatest thing since sliced bread that's
what everybody was telling me and what
you know they traded the cowboys traded
them for for an army of vikings players
holy cow and draft picks and everything
else that to me was uh also on my uh out
outside of my list here but but still
very shocking
partial was on mine as well and i meant
to mention herschel earlier when we were
talking about workout options you could
always do the 1500 push-ups per day for
the off-season program and thousands of
sit-ups per day that was herschel's
routine he never lifted weights as a kid
right when he would watch tv when the
commercials came on he would do push-ups
for the entire commercial break and he
got to the point where he's doing 1500
per day and so you know you don't need
all that fancy equipment if you just
have the will to put your hands flat on
the ground and start bending your elbows
you can do more and more and more and
more push-ups and before you know it
you're built like herschel walker but
that was a stunner when they you're not
gonna necessarily be built like herschel
walker if you do that let's let's make
sure we do 1500 a day
no you don't i don't care most people
still aren't gonna be built like
herschel walker i don't care you're
saying they're going to be he looks like
like a like a you know a greek god
without his shirt off you know might
help people get in shape and get
stronger you're not going to look like
herschel walker
he's the product of doing 1500 a day
day after day after day month after
month after month year after year after
year so you needed my machine to take
you back to when you were 10. what if
you did 1500 a day and you started when
you were 10 you would never look like
herschel walker at any point in your
life
you look better than you look now but
not better than original walker
a couple others before we take a break
here remember when donovan mcnabb was
dumped onto washington easter sunday
2010 that was one of those oh somebody's
messing with us because it was close to
you know it's easter so it's close to
april one i'm thinking somebody's got a
delayed or an early april fool's gag
there's no way in hell andy reid is
trading donovan mcnabb to washington but
that's another one that sticks out they
i i just i judge these based upon those
little moments burned into my brain
where i exactly remember where i was
when the news came down
yeah obj to the browns last year i mean
when i first heard that i was like what
is that real the browns really you know
that that was a shocker that jumped out
to me and even bill belichick quitting
the jets that was another one you know
again
wait yeah the jets are going to hire
bill belichick and then the very next
day he's quitting i mean that was kind
of a shocker too like no are you messing
with me is he really quitting like so uh
yeah that's a good one i like this trap
this was a fun one
well we'll have to remember to do it
every april 1 assuming we're on next
april 1 as well because we'll forget all
these you'll forget all these and we can
do it all over again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports